[音楽]
はい
わー
バーっ
エンド好きなんじゃあ話ぞ s みんななんと見に行ったことありますか
またの小学校の誰もがなんとかやってたと思うんですけど生とびって何が大事かって
いうとあのジャンプ力とかもちろんなんですけど結局は腕の振り回転力だと思ってるん
ですよ
そんなの改善力さえあれば20度にも全然
ああああああ
ちょっとあの個室内だからやりにくいなちょっと外で見るかやまず進んで算数を取り
できるっていうのをみんなに見せたけどいきます
この20
フィルでも三重跳び倉山できますできます小沢かちょっと思いついたんですけど
人間の何十と言って何十が限界なんだろうとちょっと調べてみましょう
人類の最高が60媚びだしですね60°3月ん類最強らしいですか
動画があるん
うわぁすげぇまずで告げる8
越えたら60度に超えたい北6時飛び越えたいという私をどうやったら人類だなぁと日
歴史を変えるかと思ったところフェチグンナーの改定だって書いてんじゃなければ
できるのかなと思いまして今回イベント取るように品準備しました
もう簡単です電動ドリルを超えて持ってここになお
カンカンでつけてボタンを押すと wii 回ペースんで開き園では出すことのでき
ないなぁの回転率
を出せるのではないかなと思います続いて今回弁道ドリルを使って史上最強だという
作り全記録
ブログジェット病声だと思いますできたーっ4まずドリルの先端になをつけていき
ましょう
眼底でいいと思うんだ
[音楽]
よし
入ってん
バイトをいただきましたん
ん
ちょっと安全を考えたサバゲー米としますとりあえず開閉速度はどんなものが待つ知り
たいとございますね
ん
あれっ
あれ紐が様札うわぁ
うわぁ
っていうねそれコードかなっちゃうやっぱ無理だ
うおおおお
さあ
[拍手]
ホラー
は終わったぁぁぁ
を纏っております
ええええええ
[音楽]
っと
あっを入力が強すぎて全部吹っ飛んでしまいました
失礼しましたややっぱドリルやばいな強さがねかなぁもう溶けてしまいました
一体今の一瞬何が起きたのでしょうか僕にはまったくわからないんですが
ただただドリルが早いということだけが分かりました
債務のでわかったことがありますあの頃僕一人だと多分出来ません桃ででようなのは全
銀河コンセントにくっついてるんで黒治療に入っちゃってる全部ぐるぐるになっちゃっ
てちょっとできないっていうことが分かりました
もうこれたら誰かに手伝ってもらわないとできないんでちょっと作戦を変えてやって
みようと思いますよ
[音楽]
さっきの回転力見てもらったら分かると思うんですけどもマジではないです
当たっても痛くない
これであればなはが当たっても巻いたがないんで大丈夫だと思います
やり方としてはもう1人だと思ってないんで外側が2人の人間に生を回してもらって
電動ドリルでをタイミングを合わせて回してもらいその中で僕が何十と日までできるか
挑戦したいと思います
ザー
まず普通になっているなる
バント世界対策ビル w
これがせーのっ
最悪スピードを共にする
がジャンプして改定して
ni
wh
goo
[音楽]
me
rar
car
ああっあああっ
ああああああ
tni
wh
ポコメロよ
3位
復活の部分
持って
えっなんだから僕にはない
月
の言っては
正直破れるん
だめだ